In this video we will talk
about Gibbs' free energy.
And more precisely how useful it is in determining this
whether a reaction would be spontaneous or not,
which is very useful in chemistry and biology.
It was first defined by Josiah Willard Gibbs.
What we see is a known formula,
which will help us predict spontaneity.
According to the formula, the change in Gibbs' free energy
is equal to the change in that 'H', which is enthalpy.
This is a change in enthalpy,
which we can consider as the heat content,
because the formula applies to
conditions with constant pressure and temperature.
This is the change in enthalpy
minus temperature multiplied by change in entropy.
The change in entropy.
'S' is entropy.
This seems like a strange, difficult-to-understand formula.
But as we shall see, it is very logical.
Joya Willard Gibbs took this formula,
to understand
how much of the enthalpy will be useful
in doing work.
How much of her is free to do good things?
But in this video we will think about it
how can we use the change in Gibbs' free energy,
to predict whether a reaction
will run spontaneously,
whether it will be spontaneous.
Let's start.
If delta G is less than 0,
the reaction will be spontaneous.
It will be spontaneous.
It will happen,
provided reagents can interact
in the right way.
It will be spontaneous.
Now let's think why this is logical.
If the expression here is negative,
the reaction will be spontaneous.
Let's think of all possible options.
In this case here,
if the enthalpy change is less than zero
and entropy is increasing,
enthalpy is decreasing.
That means we will give
energy here.
We will give enthalpy.
You can think of it like
to deliver energy.
Providing.
I will draw it.
It's the enthalpy here.
At the end I have less enthalpy than at the beginning.
But entropy is increasing.
Disorder increases the number of conditions,
which my system can accept.
There is logic in that.
It is logical
this happens spontaneously,
regardless of temperature.
I have these two molecules.
They will collide.
As they approach,
their electrons can tell,
"Wait, here's a better configuration,
in which we will reach a lower energy level,
we can give energy,
whereby
separate components are separated. "
Now we have more components.
They have separated.
We also had energy separation.
Entropy is increasing.
It is logical that this is a natural process,
which is actually happening.
This is a spontaneous reaction here.
Delta G
is less than zero.
Right here.
I will do all the spontaneous reactions -
I will surround them with this green.
What about this case here?
The delta H is greater than zero.
In this reaction, the enthalpy should be increased,
and the ethiopia will be reduced.
You can imagine these two atoms
or maybe these two molecules are getting closer,
but their electrons say, "Hey, no, no.
To get in touch.
we have to move to a higher energy level.
We will need energy,
and the disorder will be reduced.
That can not happen. "
And of course, this is a sum,
if delta H is greater than zero
and if it is less than zero,
the whole expression will be positive.
Thus delta G will be greater than zero.
Here delta G will be greater than zero.
I hope you guess,
that this reaction would not be spontaneous.
It will not happen.
Here are some variations
of delta H and delta S,
where spontaneity depends on temperature.
Here we have
delta H is less than zero.
We will have an energy release,
but entropy declines.
What will happen?
If the temperature is low,
these particles will be able to gently approach each other and
their electrons will be able to interact.
Maybe they will reach a lower energy level
and will give energy.
They give off energy,
electrons do this spontaneously.
But entropy has diminished.
This can happen,
because the temperature
here is low.
You can say,
"Wait, that does not break that
the second law of thermodynamics? "
You have to remember,
if we only think about this part
from the system, entropy is reduced.
But we have warmth.
This heat will contribute to entropy
in the rest of the system.
So the second law of thermodynamics,
saying entropy in the universe is increasing, is in effect,
thanks to the heat released.
But if we only look at those particles here,
entropy has decreased.
This reaction here too
will be spontaneous.
We always want to go back to the formula.
If this is negative and this is negative,
this will be positive.
But if T is low enough,
this expression will not matter.
If T is low, entropy does not matter much.
Then enthalpy takes control.
In this situation delta G -
Assume that T is low enough,
to make the delta G negative.
This will be spontaneous.
Let's look at the same scenario,
but if we have high temperature.
Now we have these two molecules.
Let's say these are the molecules,
maybe this purple is this one here.
we have the same two molecules here.
They can
give energy.
But here you are saying,
"Hm, see, they can ..."
Changing the enthalpy is negative.
But they pass one by the other
so fast they will not have a chance -
Their electrons will not have a chance
to interact in the right way,
to make a reaction.
This is a situation where the reaction will not be spontaneous,
because the particles will pass one by the other very quickly.
They will not be able to interact with each other properly.
You can imagine that if T is high,
if T is high, this expression will be very important.
Since entropy is negative,
this whole expression will become positive.
This will be more positive,
than it will be negative.
Therefore, this is a situation where delta G
is greater than zero.
The reaction is not spontaneous.
All I do is to give you a sense of why
Gibbs' formula for free energy is logical.
Remember this holds at constant pressure and
constant temperature.
These are reasonable assumptions when
we are dealing
with reagents in a tube
or with many of the biological systems.
Now move here.
Our enthalpy,
our change in the enthalpy is positive.
And our entropy will increase if
these particles react, but our temperature is low.
If these members react, maybe they can divide
or to do
something like that.
But they will not,
because when they collide,
they say, "Do you know? All our electrons are good.
They are in nice and stable configurations here.
I see no reason to react. "
Although, if they react,
can increase entropy.
But there is no reason to react.
If we look at these different dimensions,
if this is positive, if even this is positive,
but if T is low, it will not be able to
overcome this.
Therefore, we have a delta G greater than zero,
the reaction is not spontaneous.
If we had the same scenario,
but let's say, "Okay, let's get the temperature up here.
To increase the average kinetic energy. "
Then these particles will be able to
hitting each other.
Although the electrons
will need energy to
create these links,
the reaction may be carried out,
thanks to the disarray that has been created.
We have more possible states.
And the reaction is less likely to occur in the opposite direction,
because what is the chance
all these particles to be assembled
in the exact configuration
and return to this smaller number of molecules.
Let's take a look at these dimensions again here.
Even if delta H is greater than zero,
even if it is positive,
if the delta S is greater than zero
and T is high,
especially with the negative sign here,
this thing
will overcome the enthalpy
and the change in enthalpy,
therefore, the entire expression will be negative.
Here delta G will be less than zero.
This reaction will be spontaneous.
I hope this gave you a sense of
the Gibbs formula for free energy.
And once again,
that it implies constant pressure and temperature,
but it is useful when we think about it
whether a reaction would be spontaneous.
When looking at biological or chemical systems,
we can check the delta G for a given reaction.
We will say, "Oh, delta G is negative?"
"This will be a spontaneous reaction."
"Delta G is zero?"
"This will be a balancing reaction."
Or we can say, "This is a positive delta G."
"The reaction will not be spontaneous."